[Music]
you are so funny on starting out live
you're so amazing and you do these
amazing impressions and you do
impressions that I don't see other
people doing like your Justin Bieber is
excellent thank you so much what was
what is the key is that Justin Bieber I
don't know and I'm curious like what's
the key what is the key to inhabiting a
Justin Bieber how do you become Justin
Bieber I think it's some it's looking
like a puppy who just piddled and is
sort of sorry about it right sort of
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and he's got those jolie-pitt lips you
know you got that he has the the mass ya
know those let now have you used met
Justin Bieber obviously he hosted the
show you've met him and what were you
struck by when you met him in person
what was your impression he was very
sweet to me mm-hmm he had that face that
face that is his face on the floor yeah
he peed on the floor and then he looked
really sad about it I cleaned it I mean
we all pitched in no no he was he was
very sweet he's very beautiful to look
at he has the swagger of a gang leader
with the face of a member of the Sistine
Chapel he's a gang leader who just
relieved himself on the carpet I can't
spread my legs I cross the show but it's
you know it's that yeah yeah yeah
now you
you also do an excellent Ellen DeGeneres
impression and you actually did it to
her face you did it with Ellen on Ellen
and how did that go over did she
critique your impression did she feel it
was fair
she did say she she has been an angel
about the whole thing from the from the
get-go bless her heart
I mean so gracious she did say you know
I guess because I love to do all this
like chair stuff right yeah I don't want
my crotch out but it's cable and she was
like I've never done that on a chair I
don't know what you're doing there so
she was sort of getting in your grill a
little bit about I don't do that stop
doing but that's not what an impression
is an impression is not supposed to be
an exact representation right right
there has to be some heightened version
of the person so that was what I chose
to make up mm-hmm and raged her no no
she's very sweet you just you just
finished this is which season of SNL for
you
thank you for touching my hand that's
very nice yeah I feel connected to you
very nice it's uh I've just I've done
two seasons and then the five episodes
from one season so I worked there a long
time ago back when it was a radio show
and when I was there well everyone would
wonder what are you gonna do for the
whole summer what do you do with your
spare time you get the whole summer off
what are you gonna do are you spending
your spare time
oh my goodness I have I have been
searching for cats
for cats you want a cat you've heard of
trap neuter release what are you talking
about I guess that's the thing women do
you wouldn't have heard of it
no no I've been going to catch shelters
and I've been I've been you know wanting
a cat in my life and I'm I've been doing
that way too often
wait so you go to cat shelters and you
haven't found the cat yeah just I just
shop just look around I found one
there was one we'll call him John I
won't use his real name because I don't
want to embarrass him but I felt I saw
his picture on the Internet like a
craigslist style and then I went to meet
him in person and he rebuked me didn't
like you me to me and I thought buster
imma imma give you the life here and he
would rather live with 25 other cats
than with me I've never felt more
rejected in my life maybe I came on too
strong because they did I did go to him
and say well he'd be my cat husband
please husband
you